Dexter the twisted tale of a serial
killer with a moral code was a massive
ratings hit for Showtime it was also an
influential series that prompted a slew
of similarly lethal anti-heroes on TV
now it's time to conduct an autopsy on
the show's conclusion when Dexter was
just two years old his mother was
brutally killed at the hands of a cartel
boss and he and his brother were left
sitting in her blood
at first the audience is encouraged to
believe that this foundational trauma is
what put Dexter down the path to being a
serial killer
when Dexter's adopted father Harry
realizes his son lacks emotional empathy
and might possibly be a sociopath like
when he finds Dexter killing
neighborhood pets
he teaches Dexter a code so the child
won't get caught the code of Harry my
foster father is satisfied but by the
end of Dexter his story is far more
complicated as it turns out it was a
criminal psychiatrist who had come up
with the code Harry was only responsible
for teaching it to Dexter and it wasn't
until Dexter's first kill that he
finally understood the monster he'd
helped create it would be years before
Dexter learned that his father's death
had been at his own hands once he
realized what his adopted son was
capable of one of the most compelling
things about Dexter is his incredible
level of self-awareness
according to professionals it's this
introspection that makes him an
unrealistic psychopath in spite of being
so relatable to viewers he struggles in
society just as we all do but in
Dexter's case he struggles with feeling
empathy and love even though he
understands what it looks like just like
me empty inside as the narrative
progresses from the beginning to the end
of Dexter we see him go from someone who
must imitate human emotion to a man who
actually does feel and comes to truly
care about those closest to him in fact
it's this emotional development that
causes Dexter to get so many people
around him hurt or killed in the
anthology the psychology of Dexter
author Christopher Ryan writes Dexter is
both cold-blooded killer and
warm-hearted family man
unfeeling assassin and supportive friend
like all of us he is confused yet
he's the best and worst we can be often
simultaneously
Dexter's audience is so focused on what
he'll get away with next that a key
aspect of the show often gets overlooked
if America's criminal justice system
actually worked better and criminals
weren't set free by means of legal
loopholes or skilled defense attorneys
there would be no need for vigilantes
like Dexter so when he sets his sights
on unfairly freed predators Dexter is
highlighting a real life crisis in
America and in a way his actions are
making the world a little bit safer for
women and children on the flip side
Dexter also shows us how easy it is to
game the law enforcement system from the
inside Harry's code insists that the
person Dexter targets must be a killer
or other kind of confirmed monster but
since Dexter is able to change
information in a computer database it
only takes a few keystrokes to release
someone as his own prey on the occasion
he gets bored and needs a victim this
system is how Dexter eventually
identifies the men responsible for his
mother's death and because of his
easygoing persona there are few people
who ever strongly suspect something is
off with Dexter at least until much
later on in this story
Perry's code defines Dexter's approach
to vigilante justice but it isn't
foolproof and the more human Dexter
becomes through his relationships both
at home and at work
the more he exposes the innocent people
around him to the collateral damage of
his targets on top of that Dexter
happens to be a consummate risk taker
and his exploits get more and more
dangerous as the years go by in season
two there sergeant Doakes the first
person outside of Dexter's family to
suspect there's something wrong with him
Doakes is killed by Dexter's
ex-girlfriend Lila who does it in an
effort to protect him what's worse at
least for Doakes is that Dexter manages
to pin his own crimes on the detective
ruining his stellar record posthumously
nobody goes to Doakes funeral in season
3 Dexter unleashes a real monster with
district attorney Miguel Prado when
Prado finds out who Dexter really is he
wants to learn Harry's code the code
winds up meaning nothing however and
Prado goes on to kill a rival attorney
who is about to expose his corruption by
season 7
Dexter's lieutenant Maria LaGuerta
learns his true identity and launches an
investigation into Doakes innocence
ultimately it forces Dexter sister Deb
to choose between him and her colleague
Deb chooses her brother but not without
great personal loss but arguably the
worst death that Dexter has set in
motion is that of his eventual wife Rita
throughout season 4 Dexter engages in a
push and pull with Arthur Miller aka the
Trinity killer who targets victims based
on their similarities to his own family
although Dexter is ultimately successful
in putting Arthur on his table he leaves
room for Rita to be the last
Trinity kill and in a symbolic turn of
events that has since been named one of
the most shocking television deaths of
all time
Arthur leaves Dexter's son Harrison
sitting in a pool of his mother's blood
just as Dexter was when Harry found him
as a child other crime shows may wait
until later seasons before really amping
up the stakes but Dexter has his crimes
come to light by the show's second
season when divers find his dumping
ground off the Miami Coast dubbed the
Bay Harbor butcher
Dexter's true identity remains unknown
and because of his position in the
police department even assists in the
lab work for his own crimes this tension
does a great deal for Dexter's character
development right off the bat
Harry had taught him never to get caught
and because of his intellect
Dexter thought he had the system beat
but when his dumping ground is revealed
it's an enormous reality check that
grounds Dexter for a few years the Bay
Harbor butcher also marks a turning
point in Dexter's arc where collateral
deaths that don't meet the standard of
Harry's code begin in earnest Dexter
frames sergeant Doakes for his murders
although he has no intention of killing
him but Dexter's former lover Lila
becomes so obsessed with him that she's
driven to kill Doakes hopeful that
Dexter will love her in return she's
wrong and winds up being the next Bay
Harbor butcher victims like Hannibal
Lecter Dexter is one of the few serial
killers viewers actually root for even
after he gets innocent folks killed
Michael see Hall's fierce yet
compassionate performance is a big
reason
Dexter feels so human his internal
monologue courtesy of the Dexter writers
room is another but for some Dexter
isn't just someone to root for people
think they found their own personal
Batman people have actually committed
real-life crimes because they felt
related to him on such a deep level
maybe the show made Dexter a little bit
too real too sympathetic and too
relatable then again
Dexter's kill list is really really long
so now that we've seen the ending of
Dexter we should probably be thankful
more people haven't been inspired by his
laundry list of crimes at the beginning
of the show Dexter is convinced that he
can't be in a proper relationship
because physical intimacy would likely
reveal his inner monster to the other
person Rita seems perfect to him because
as an assault survivor she isn't
interested in the physical at all she's
perfect because Rita is in her own way
as damaged as me eventually however it
does become a factor in their
relationship and when Dexter joins
Narcotics Anonymous to provide a cover
for his activities he gets a beautiful
sponsor in Lila and discovers that he
actually is a physical person but only
with people who really see him things
are further complicated when Rita gets
pregnant and Dexter feels obligated to
play father both to that child and to
Rita's other kids
after Rita's tragic death Dexter is sure
he'll be alone for the rest of his life
and he sort of okay with it but then he
meets lumen the barrel girl survivor and
realizes that he misses having a partner
especially a partner who understands him
as deeply as Lila did Dexter ultimately
meets his match in Hannah McKay another
serial killer who falls in love with him
as he does with her for Dexter his
experience of both love and physical
intimacy comes from the women who
recognized and appreciate his
monstrousness and his humanity arguably
the most important woman in Dexter's
life is his adopted sister Debra Debra
is Dexter's grounding force constantly
reminding him of the good she sees in
him
in many ways Deborah is Dexter's living
conscience but for Debra the
relationship is far more complicated in
season one she winds up in the middle of
a bloody back in
forth between Dexter and his biological
brother another serial killer known as
the ice-truck killer he kidnaps and
tortures Deborah in an attempt to bond
with Dexter and the experience leaves
her traumatized and emotionally
dependent on her brother Deborah's
relationship bad luck would continue
throughout the series when another of
her boyfriends becomes the target of a
serial killer named the Skinner the
experience triggers Deborah's earlier
trauma she ultimately finds comfort in a
much older man and colleague but
tragically he too leaves her life when
he's shot and killed
Deborah's shoot-from-the-hip style
brings her career highs and lows from
vice to homicide detective to lieutenant
after she discovers her beloved brother
is a serial killer she joins the private
sector as an investigator complicating
things further Deborah realizes that her
feelings for Dexter are not just family
loves she goes against everything she
believes in when she kills LaGuerta to
save her brother the experience puts her
on the eventual downward spiral that
leads to her untimely death Dexter
Hannah and his son Harrison are just
about to ride off into the Buenos IDUs
sunset to live happily ever after when
Dexter gets sloppy again he leaves
fellow serial killer Oliver Saxon alive
in order for Debra to arrest him but
Oliver frees himself and shoots Deborah
in the stomach severely wounding her
when Dexter realizes that he's the one
responsible for Deborah getting shot and
put on life support he understands that
he will never have a happy ending he
sends Hannah and Harrison to Buenos IDs
without him takes Deborah off life
support and fakes his own death Dexter
had always worried Harrison would turn
out to be a monster like him in the end
Harrison is left to be raised by another
serial killer in another country with no
idea that his father is still alive
could this be the perfect setup for a
Dexter spinoff years down the road
featuring Harrison after the death of
his sister and the loss of his son and
lover
Dexter's internal monologue disappears
by the end of Dexter's eighth and final
season he is empty he has come to terms
of the fact that it's not safe for him
to be around people especially not
innocent people he loves lumberjack
Dexter lives alone in a
in the woods which begs the question as
he stopped killing he no longer has
access to a police database and can't
vet victims / Harry's code but
throughout the show Dexter makes it
clear that he doesn't have a choice in
killing he needs it to survive so after
the end of Dexter who and how is he
killing now the ambiguous closing shot
of a bearded Dexter silently staring
into the camera certainly leaves a lot
of room for future seasons check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]